hello everybody hope they are good quick
Bitcoin update for today so far we are
still inside this range this is your
range highs these are your French lows
okay here you have your mid-range and
these are your range quarters okay
um you know so we're still in this
structure on the highs because you know
if you zoom out
you can see that we're at the highs okay
now well you have to try to figure out
is what's more likely the price you know
breaks out above the range highs or
below the range lows okay I'll tell you
what I think I want to go through the
chart in a minute I think that if we go
into the one hour time frame we can get
some more information okay and the thing
that I don't like in this chart is that
if you notice every time that there are
you know well at the highs we see some
kind of you know large green candle or a
long week and then price gets rejected
straight away you can see here large
green candle price gets reacted okay
again if we go through
you have here a couple of a couple of
large screen candles price gets rejected
a week price gets rejected okay we
continue another Larson candle price
gets reacted a week price gets rejected
okay we continue no problem here more
large screen candles okay price gets
reacted again large city Scandal price
gets rejected and we can continue all
the time like this okay so why is I
telling you well I think in my opinion
that's telling me that the market make
it is building their shorts
okay under building the shorts
are the highest zones in this range
right now if you're going to the forward
our time frame
we can see here you know that we took a
deviation
above the range size okay now the
question is what's that deviation enough
we're gonna go in a minute through high
block Capital because yes the resisted
call of liquidity here at 31 700 so okay
so it makes you think why
you know defeat Thirty one thousand five
hundred why for 200 difference okay this
is the difference
why I didn't even hit this level here
and hit all those liquidations before
dropping price
well usually when that happens is
because the market make it is you know
trying to build more liquidity in this
song okay just because if you don't hate
all those liquidations and then you are
moving in this Zone
then anybody that is short in here with
high leverage it's going to have their
Liquidations in this Zone okay so at the
end you know if you had here let's say
you know one billion worth of
liquidations you know now here maybe you
have two all right of course as an
example don't take those numbers because
you know I'll just make them making them
up but that's what I mean so a thirty
one thousand seven hundred I know that
that is quite a lot of liquidity here
okay now
if you notice here we've had this first
stop
the second tab now the question is is it
possible that we have you know
another top to the upside maybe up all
the way here to 31 700 hit or those
liquidations and then price can drop you
know below this range okay because yeah
here you have a lot of inefficiencies in
the chart look at this okay all these
large candles are inefficiencies their
liquidity pools that have to get
retraced okay so that's what is telling
me that the scenario that I'm favoring
at the moment is
a breakout below this range okay
possibly another deviation
now uh if we don't get the deviation I
think we will okay but if we don't get
the deviation at 31 700 then
there is still an interesting Zone in
the chat because if I look at this chart
I think that you know catches my eye the
most is this week over here okay let me
Mark it for you this could be 100 of the
week it's actually a thirty one thousand
five hundred okay round number
foreign
thousand five hundred okay
that's like that's not a coincidence
guys that's pretty interesting in fact
but then you have here
okay the 50 of the week are here that
it's around here 31
175 okay that's the fifty percent of the
way now the quick filler strategy says
that
at least the 50 of the week has to get
filled okay now yesterday we made our
attempt to the upside
but we didn't really uh get to the 50 of
the week you can see here okay
there we've got to Thirty One Thousand
forty five dollars kind of okay
so this one here
is not taking yet okay
again you know that we hit 31 175
doesn't mean that from here we have to
dump okay they can still you know go for
you know 100 of the week or even this
deviation here but the Wakefield
strategy say is that at least the 50 of
the week has to get filled that's what
we know so you know if you are looking
into longs
then this would be your take profits
okay where do you take profits you know
the most of your position but we have a
problem and is that we have tomorrow the
CPI data
okay
so what I think is that today you know
it's it's very likely that we arrange
in this song we'll do some kind of
sideways move okay
and nothing really happens okay I think
that the beat came up is gonna happen
tomorrow usually the day before CPI data
or you know or fomc they like to you
know move price sideways they like to
wait until those
until the data comes out okay so that's
what I think for today otherwise you
know uh now how could you have taken
advantage of this move to the upside
yesterday
well
to be honest it wasn't that difficult
when I go here 4 Hour 50ma okay now we
can see that we are currently above the
4 Hour 50ma so as long as we are above
this level
I think we're fine the problem is that
we are you know right below the
mid-range you know so we're right now
if tomorrow was in CPI day then today
as soon as I saw a close of a candle
above the mid-range
do you know support then you know long
long very confident towards the week but
the problem is what I've told you that
tomorrow's API so it's likely that you
know we do some sideways until tomorrow
and then tomorrow we'll see what happens
because tomorrow you know we're in a
market driven by data mainly so
the data is going to make a difference
of what's going to happen tomorrow in
terms of price Action Now yesterday how
could you take advantage of this move
well
I was telling you one of the scenarios
was
in CPI data that we see a deviation here
I've said I don't want this here A
deviation below the range lows if you
see a tomorrow elevation below range
lows okay then that could be an
opportunity
too long as soon as we can get back into
the range okay that's one one idea about
the other idea that I was saying
yesterday was you know a push up
a retrace into the mid-range or the 50ma
in the forward time frame and then long
okay that was one of the scenarios this
yesterday
this happened yesterday
well they didn't reaches the 4r50 may
but if you're going to the one hour time
frame okay you're gonna see how they
taste the mid-range
very clearly here okay check that out
that's the perfect you know resistance
support flip
and then that's when you can long okay
to the next Target now this the problem
is that tomorrow we have CPI okay so
we're expecting sideways move today but
if we don't have CPI tomorrow then
what I would tell you guys is that you
know with we are right now above the
4r50 main we're testing a support all
this time it has been resistance here
you can see and it has been pushing
price down but now we're above it okay
yes we are below the mid-range but the
the difference in price is you know uh
less than a hundred dollars so I will
tell you that is very likely that price
would eventually come above the
mid-range and then that's when you know
price would go for this Equity pool here
for example
okay and of course towards this week he
had the 50 even 100 and even this
liquidation zone are 31 700 so I will
tell you you know if tomorrow was in CPI
Bay I will tell you the Char is looking
good for longs I'm gonna favor longs
that's what I will tell you but today
I cannot tell you that because we have
CPI tomorrow so today I think it could
be a bad day for day Traders
if I'm honest with you I don't think
that we are going to see much going on
but you know if you have scalpad and you
go into the five minutes time frame one
minute time frame I'm sure you can find
some opportunities now we're gonna go
into high block Capital we're gonna try
to spot where the liquidity is okay but
you know in advance I can tell you that
the chart is telling me that the
liquidity is to the upside okay
capital okay these are the liquidation
levels uh so far you can see that you
know there were a lot of sorts at risk
because you can sell off sort
liquidations okay
um then you know price this short
squeeze stopped all those uh swords and
now the Delta is you know pretty much
back to back to one okay so you know
it's it's quite neutral at the moment
but if you check at the right of the
chart and you then you check for these
spikes you can see the spikes you know
the highest amount of liquidity are to
the upside you go here a 30 671
177 Million worth of
short liquidations that um in a times 50
leverage okay that's a law of liquidity
but obviously you have more respects to
the upside check this out uh sorry that
would be
I think hang on what am I here
uh there you go 31
273 I think that's around the the week
that I was mentioning guys and even
higher okay another is pack what is this
31 000 hang on here 31
869 this could be the deviation that
we're talking about okay
so you can see how these three spikes
matches with you know or logic behind
the chart now we're gonna go into the
liquidation hitmap we can see here more
visual
okay 12 hours time frame it's probably
not much telling me because we're on a
sideways move yeah exactly no no no it's
not much in there now if you're going to
the seven days time frame I'm sure we
can find some more things here
okay uh yep check this out the brightest
bar it's at 31
350. okay that's around that's pretty
much the week that I was telling you
about guys okay so you can see that you
know there have been a lot of
liquidations above that zone
um in fact
to the downside we still have some
liquidity but
uh I like this song better okay and of
course if you're going to the Walmart
time frame it's going to be even clearer
so let's check this out
but here
so when I see what I was talking about
guys all right check this out you know
we already had here a 31 700 a lot of
liquidity okay
we had a lot of liquidity here
and what is interesting is that they hit
31 500 well even you know spike a bit
further to hit this liquidation so
that's what is telling me that what they
try to do here is to increase the
liquidations here so when price comes
back to it and hit them
they're gonna hit even more liquidity
okay and they're gonna do it in a more
efficient way so that's what I'm telling
you guys the liquidity at the moment in
my opinion is to the upside at least you
know uh Thirty One Thousand seven
hundred thirty one thousand eight
hundred and from there if we see a
reaction get back inside the range you
know that's a perfect swing short
opportunity okay where to well I will be
targeting then a breakout below range
lows okay and I'm telling you that would
be you know 29k 28 500 that's possible
okay that's what I think I know a lot of
people are screaming for 32k 40K 50K 60k
but I don't care about those you know
about those targets I'm only kidding
what's gonna happen in the next you know
one two days that's what I care about so
so for now I would favor liquidity to
the upside to get taken first and then a
potential deviation above the range
highs on a breakout below the range loss
finally okay uh the problem is again
tomorrow we have CPI so expect for today
some kind of sideways move
and then tomorrow
see what the data is uh the preview CPI
data was four percent they are targeting
they're expecting a three to one percent
so let's see what the actual data comes
out okay before I finish the video let
me say thank you for all the support to
the website you know
um the course is getting fully booked
pretty quickly you have here uh both
groups of photos have been fully booked
the first group of September fully
booked and now we have only one group
for September and two groups but you
know doesn't took a book for example
second group of sorry the first group of
October
places in the stock okay so if you are
interested in Booking the the course of
course first go through the website and
you have here some questions and answers
here you have the course details
what you're gonna learn and then also
you have a description
here okay so thank you so much guys for
watching the video and I'll see you soon